có một lần bà hỏi như thế nào, sả trị nhàng không có cổng cầm cầm lưỡa.
Một phần người dân môi trường của lưỡa là cổng tiếp xúc cưa lại cao cầm chí trong con cao là bổ.
Nên là được nghe thông tin được cao trị hất là nhiều, có một lần bà hỏi như thế nào.
Ở hỏi mà là mẹ ơi, trong đổi thiết có có chí hơn là mình là hậu lúc bố.
Ná hỏi là mẹ ơi, chí hơn là chíu có dậy thì đúng không, nè.
Sau yên, cũng xúc có lệ hỏi gì vậy?
Vên ra tài sau con hỏi dậy mà có biết dậy thì lấy dậy không.
sau mà cái bản cá lời là tài vì không nghe chỉ hơn nói dân đó,
là chỉ hơn chú có đủng dau,
chức này sẽ chức không chứ?
Chị phải chết, có lần bản hỏi là
mặc có suy lại gì mà,
rồi mặc có suy lại đầm,
ở để ý ở dưới dụng trong cái gì mà,
phản dụng cái thời gian mà, trong những lúc yêu đương không có hoàn mẹ.
Tị, mình cũng rất là bất ngờ thì mình nghĩ
lúc đó thì em lại chỉ biết là
cái này ở từ tờ đầm hỏi,
và rồi có lần mà có biết khi không chưa mẹ cũng chưa biết nữa.
Nó là những cái mà mình,
mình rất là bất ngờ khi mà
còn đã biết được như vậy rồi,
rất là còn cũng đã nè được tờ các anh chảy và chỉ như là
ngày nào cũng rồi chú ý có con,
để nghe có là thong tình hôm nay có mặc được,
nó là những cái gì,
để mà mình biết được là,
cái gì cũng thế giày ra thì mà mình sẽ bắt đầu mình
mình có cách đến mà mình sẽ lý.